well at least I won't die alone well
that's just typical
[Music]
that's what this doesn't get messy
this is where it begins captain
this is where the frontier pushes back
what the hell is this I know why you're
here why we are all here
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's never do that again
hey youtubers is Charlie so first
official trailer for Star Trek beyond
starting to look a lot more like classic
Trek we're in the frontier there's a
sexy alien that Kirk might end up having
sex with and they're getting into all
kinds of trouble if you sense something
familiar about the kinetic pace of the
trailer like just like the way there was
so much action the movie was directed by
Justin Lin who directed all the best
Fast & Furious movies and the funny
thing about that is that they're
boosting a space shuttle at the
beginning of this trailer just like they
boost cars all over the Fast and Furious
movies in the song you know the sabotage
song was playing when Kirk stole his
father's car
so that's why when Scotty's like wait is
this is this a song as this music and
Kirk is like that's actually a pretty
good choice he just he's remembering
stealing his dad's car you can see the
way the trailer messes with the timeline
of the narrative of the trailer then
jumps back to the enterprise getting
destroyed it's not a Star Trek movie if
they don't blow and Enterprise up don't
worry there's plenty of letters left in
the alphabet as Scotty always said but
the whole idea with this movie is that
they're on that five-year mission that
they were talking about during Star Trek
into darkness
so they are on the frontier so it's much
closer to classic Trek you know Wild
West gun slinger action which is why the
you know there's so much action in this
so it feels kind of like Star Trek fast
and furious a couple of the biggest
complaints I've seen about the trailer
is just that there is so much action but
I think they're just cherry picking all
the biggest moments that they want to go
on in a big note this is probably gonna
be the last Star Trek movie they haven't
confirmed that yet at least not that I
know of but they didn't really cut this
trailer for classic Trek fans they cut
it for people that don't know anything
about Star Trek so they're like ooh you
know lots of crazy space action we you
know maybe this would be fun we'll go
see it
later when we get more trailers we'll
probably see more of that classic Trek
action Simon Pegg actually wrote the
screenplay for this and he is one of the
biggest Star Trek geeks on the planet
and he's a great writer too so I have a
lot of faith in him now we don't really
know anything about the aliens in the
movie only that the villain Idris Elba
looks a little bit like a JEM Hadar but
I don't think he's gem dar in the
timeline right now the founders would
still be in the Gamma Quadrant building
their JEM Hadar legions or growing them
in vats I'm guessing in the in the vein
of like a lot of these previous Star
Trek JJ Abrams films it's something that
we've heard about but we haven't seen a
whole lot before I am curious to see if
it's like a race that we've seen before
but they've just changed the look like
they did that with Klingons JJ Abrams
changed the look of Klingons for his
films we get to see some classic Trek
mountain climbing Kirk style
only this time Scotty
gets to do it bones in spock running
into some trouble looks like it's like
the same type of drones that destroyed
the enterprise classic bones one-liner
just him being like I'm in the [ __ ] now
dirt by Kirk and this alien that looks
like she ends up helping Kirk you might
not recognize her because she has so
much makeup on but she was the really
badass ninja with the blades four legs
in Kingsman Secret Service the new
uniforms look pretty good I don't
actually own any Star Trek uniforms I
really like the classic ones just
because they're solid colors but the
more modern ones are actually like way
more practical so if you're gonna get a
Star Trek uniform I'd advise you going
with one of like the JJ Abrams era ones
because they look like the classic
uniforms but they're just a little more
comfortable another new alien don't know
who this is or what race they're from
and we see the crew the enterprise being
rounded up looks like after the
enterprise crashes on this planet here's
Keynes err from the previous Star Trek
films he's gonna be back Ahura pulling a
reverse Felicity from era if you guys
watched arrow last week curt midair
saved for the win and Idris Elba rearing
his head the interesting thing about
this film is we really don't know much
about the narrative not nearly as much
as we know about Star Wars going into
that or any of the Marvel films so we
have a pretty blank slate it just it
looks like the Federation pushes into
territory that's controlled by Idris
Elba and he just isn't having it and he
goes all Luther on their asses if you
guys haven't watched Luther Idris Elba
as a badass than that you know a very
different tone obviously from Star Trek
but it's a great series so overall it
does feel like a lot of fun we're
inching closer to classic but the energy
of the science fiction Western that like
Deep Space 9 and the classic Trek were
that was actually my favorite Star Trek
series was Deep Space 9 less Federation
more outer territories which is kind of
looks like where they're going here but
let me know in the comments below what
do you guys think about this trailer so
far like this crazy you know fast and
furious Star Trek remember the biggest
part of the Fast and Furious movies
after the plot stopped revolving around
car races it started revolving more
around the idea of family like what
would you do how far would you go for
your family so just expect that theme to
continue in Star Trek because that core
Star Trek group those characters are
family boosting spaceships meeting hot
aliens having sex with them all kinds of
classic Trek all over this now the movie
isn't coming out to the end of July so
we're probably not gonna see like the
full length of even bigger trailer for
at least another month or two usually
when you get about six months out is
when they drop the first really big
trailer but I think they wanted to
capitalize on Star Wars being asked to
the like hey you know space opera why
don't you see the trailer for this other
big space movie they're really like a
bunch of people that have that idea
they're gonna be a ton of really big
trailers playing ahead of Star Wars in
theaters and if you go to Star Wars in
3d they're gonna be some special 3d
trailers I know there's at least a 3d
Deadpool trailer it's going to be
playing in front of Star Wars it's not
going to be the red band trailer because
Star Wars is only pg-13 but it's still
gonna be pretty cool what's probably
gonna happen is is we have the 12 days
of Deadpool that are happening if you
guys didn't see my Deadpool video I'll
put a link in the description there's
gonna be like 12 days of new content
every single day we have Star Wars this
week I will be doing a non-spoilery Star
Wars review first and then like the day
after that or something like that I'll
do my spoiler review because a lot of
you guys might not be able to see the
movie right away so be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'll totally do some
more Star Wars giveaways the next time I
post a Star Wars video well guys wait
for everything to post you can click
here for the Deadpool teaser to learn
all about the 12 days of Deadpool and
you can click here for all my Star Wars
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you
[Music]